A little lesser percentage of the
learners who will be joining today,
but anyway,
we can have a discussion later on,
so if there are any queries to come up.
So,
so today I'm going to talk about the
Module Two.
We will get into Module Two,
which is on fundamentals of AI. So,
why this module is something which I have
already briefed? Basically,
we want to understand what is the...
Is that daddb?
plus the evolution of AI. So we get to,
when we are using such models,
when we are using the agents, et cetera,
we know what is,
what category it belongs to or what is
the technology behind based on which it
is working, how it works, et cetera.
So, without that knowledge,
if you get into directly using them,
we might be.
a little not clear in our decision making
or the strategy we would like to apply.
So that is the idea behind.
We will not get into too technical about
the model or behind its working, etc.
You have multiple elective courses which
you can pick in the later part of the
program where you can get to understand
more about the technical details behind
each of them.
So for some of you who are working in
this field or who are already ML or AI
engineers,
this might be fundamental in nature or
this might be something which you are
already aware of. So in that case,
you can feel free to
skip out or you can consider this as a
basic refresher. So with that,
I will start today. Operationally,
two things I want to mention.
One is on the request which has come for
the class change. I have not yet got.
the go ahead from the division.
So this week we will have anyway,
we'll have a class tomorrow at 550 only.
By next week I will get it,
see if it can be reassigned to the
morning.
So tomorrow we go as per plan in the
evening at 550.
The second thing I wanted to convey is on
the.
quiz.
So as informed in the announcements as
well as in the previous class,
the quiz will open from August 23rd,
which will consist of topics still
covered till tomorrow.
That is first CS1 to CS5.
That would be the plan for the quiz.
And with that,
I will go ahead on the topics.
So,
if you take the fundamentals of
artificial intelligence,
we are trying to mimic the human
intelligence or mimic human thought
process, right? So,
the artificial intelligence as a field
itself.
It takes a lot of things from computer
science to mathematics and data,
through which we are trying to create the
human intelligence.
So when we say human intelligence,
there are four main capabilities we will
say,
or these are the cognitive pillars which
we would require for an AI to have so
that it can do what humans do,
or it can process information and make
decisions.
like humans. So it means learning,
reasoning, problem solving,
and perception.
Problem solving is in some cases it's
called as action. Of course,
there are a few other it needs to
remember, context, memory,
all that are there.
But the four main ways in which AI are
implemented or AI.
has evolved is what we are going to talk
about. Now if you look at...
AI,
artificial intelligence as a word has
been existing for a very long time.
It didn't start in this decade or it
didn't start just a few years back.
So previous AIs,
initially we call them as narrower AI or
weak AI.
They were focusing on a specific task.
AI was designed for a specific task.
For example,
a translation or a playing a chess,
image generation.
right?
And then slowly it went into more of a
more of general AI, general intelligence,
and that is what we are marching today.
So general AI is AGI or strong AI.
It says that theoretically AI possesses
human level cognitive
capabilities across any domain.
And now again,
there are different opinions.
Some of them say that today we have
achieved a GI, but still there are many.
Problems in that,
and there is certain limitations to that,
etc. Now, the core technical pillars.
of achieving the human-like intelligence
capabilities is through learning,
reasoning, perception,
and problem solving.
All the core technical pillars behind to
achieve all this is the algorithms,
the machine learning algorithms,
the primary mechanism which was driving
the modern PI.
So instead of hard coding explicit rules.
Models started looking at the patterns
and making predictions by looking at the
data, large data sets.
And then we had the deep learning,
which went into the neural networks,
which was inspired by the biological
brain.
So,
DL or deep learning looks at complex
tasks like computer vision.
Many of our large language models today
are powered by the base of deep learning,
which we will look at a little more in
detail. Apart from these MLDL algorithms,
and the way they learn or how they make
the brain, etc.
Data and compute was also one of the core
technical pillars.
So high quality data acts as a training
fuel, as well as the compute, hardware,
GPU and specialized chip.
They provide the processing power because
we are not dealing with small data
anymore.
We are always dealing with large data set.
For a machine learning algorithm to
analyze the identified patterns and make
predictions,
it cannot do with a smaller number of
data sets.
It needs high amount of processing power.
So required to run complex calculations,
et cetera. So with this,
the core functional capabilities for
perception,
extracting data or structure from a raw
world inputs, right? So computer vision,
images, all for the videos, etc.
Understanding the natural language,
interpreting and generating human
languages, reasoning,
evaluating scenarios, applying logic,
look at sequential steps to achieve the
next goals, etc. And then
Problem solving is more of action and
autonomy. Executing choices is autonomous,
as well as also have a pipeline of
software products or have a pipeline to
execute choices independently.
Etcetera.
Right,
so let's look at each of these four
cognitive pillars, I would say,
or the four capabilities that allow AI.
to mimic the human world or make
human-like decisions in a little more in
detail. So let's start with learning.
So, learning is again the base.
through which AI can improve its
performance. All of us do that day-to-day,
right? Day in, day out. We learn.
We don't stop learning. Like,
how do we improve ourselves? We learn.
We keep learning,
so that is what machine learning does. So,
AI, when it is not learning,
it is confined,
it does one particular task and it
doesn't improve further,
but learning what makes AI improve its
performance over.
by looking at the data patterns from the
data, etc. So the earlier rule-based AIs,
if you talk about,
they were just hard-coded rules.
They don't improve it even if you execute
10 times or even if you execute with
millions of data.
They are going to give you same results
or accuracy,
but whenever a machine learning,
you talk about a machine learning model,
it applies that.
And that is where you are able to have
improved performance.
So you can see three diagrams here.
Like this is basically the machine
learning.
paradigms or how AI does machine learning
or how we do the learning. Basically,
if you look at machine learning models,
there are three main categories.
Deep learning is not treated as a
separate category because it comes under
unsupervised.
only.
So supervised learning is basically the
classic machine learning.
Bad human.
experts have already labeled the training
data. Okay, so for example,
the most common example is a spam or a
not spam in an e-mail.
So there are hundreds and millions of
data, mail data,
which has been tagged as spam,
as not spam,
and you have the labeling already
available.
And then the supervised learning.
Model or the algorithm during training
uses these labels to infer the
characteristics. It looks at the data,
it's used statistics or the relationship
between the data, the features, and then..
.
learns it and then it uses that
information during whatever it has
learned in the training to predict the
future.
pattern and so a future e-mail which
comes in as a spam or a not spam.
The same can be applied to images.
A data scientist trains an image
recognition model to recognize dogs and
cats.
So it trains the model with hundreds of
images of dogs and cats as well as
talks about key features which the model
should take into consideration, like size,
shape, the fur, etc.,
with the primary labeling.
So the model during the training uses the
labels to infer the visual
characteristics,
typically of a dog and a cat, and then
use it to predict it.
So that's supervised learning.
So now what happens in supervised
learning is you need the label.
You require a human labeled training data
or a verified data.
Whereas, in unsupervised learning,
does not assume.
the labels to be there.
It can be a right or a wrong answer.
and it does not require labeling.
These algorithms detect inherent patterns
in data sets to cluster the data points
into groups and then come up with
prediction.
So many e-commerce businesses like Amazon,
they use association models,
association rules,
to power the recommendation engines, etc.
So that's one example of unsupervised
learning.
basic unsupervised learning.
So it does not use labels.
It clusters and identifies patterns, etc.
So, those are the two main classes.
The third one is the reinforcement
learning. So in reinforcement learning,
a model learns holistically by trial and
error through the system rewarding of
correct output or penalization when it
comes to incorrect output.
Okay,
so reinforcement models are mainly they
learn from their experiences, right?
They use a trial and error method,
and there is a reward pattern or
penalties whenever there is.
Mistake being done,
so that's how reinforcement learning is
the third category,
and there are many places we will use
reinforcement learning,
but today we are using it in almost all,
but these are basic examples when they
started to be used, etc. Now,
where does the...
Deep learning fitness,
deep learning is a evolved subset of
unsupervised learning,
where neural networks is one type of
unsupervised learning which happens to
mimic the human brain.
So,
we will not get into what is neural
networks,
but a basic understanding is there are
multiple layers of interconnected nodes
progress through the data.
The data goes through each of these
interconnected nodes.
They extract the key features.
While they pass through each layer,
they identify the relationships and they
refine their decision making at each
throughout the process,
called as forward propagation.
So, there are,
if you imagine a neural network,
there are many pictures in the internet,
you can just see what is it how neural
networks looks like and what is a
multi-layer perceptron, etcetera, and all.
But, to be in very simple terms,
There are many interconnected nodes which
progressively take the data,
extract the key features,
identify relationships,
and take decisions,
and also find this decision in a process
of forward propagation.
And there is also something called as
back propagation,
which go backs and recorrects
our model calculates the error.
So it does one cycle and it founds out
the error is this,
so it goes back and changes the weights
and biases accordingly.
So that's what is called as back
propagation, so it recalculates the error,
etc.
So today, most used large language models,
most advanced AI applications which use
the large language models,
covering all of our chat based AIs,
et cetera, they utilize deep learning.
But the problem with this is
It requires.
a lot of tremendous computational
resources. So though it learns,
it has to learn from a lot of data.
So a lot of resources plus data,
compute and data is required in deep
learning.
Right. Now,
what differentiates a normal rule-based
AI from the machine learning models or
the deep learning models is the learning
part.
AI models were used in the early days,
like export systems, rule-based engines,
etc.
Most of they are called a symbolic AI.
They were able to automate decision
making,
but only models which are capable of
learning, the machine learning,
are able to optimize their performance
over time.
So that is the point you have to take.
A very important point you have to take
is
We can have a very simple model,
rule-based engine or export systems,
which rely on if-then statements,
or I will talk about symbolic logic
systems shortly.
But these are systems which are intact.
They are hard.
bound rules. There are rule engines,
expert systems which are there,
and they don't involve any ML.
So while all ML models can be called as
an AI, not AI involvement,
it doesn't mean that all AI involves ML.
There are the most basic ones are the
ones which...
are just rule-based systems who don't
learn anything,
they just execute based on the rules, etc.
But when it comes to machine learning,
that is where the learning came in.
They use statistical information.
So they use statistical AI rather than
the symbolic Q AI.
And then they learn.
Rule-based AI models have to be
explicitly programmed.
But ML models are trained by applying
their mathematical frameworks to a data
set.
And those data for minds which are there,
they serve as the model's future,
how the model's future performance
how it fits into the real world
predictions,
all that is based on the data sets and
the relationship between the data,
exactly. So with that ML model, again,
the learning can happen as supervised
learning, unsupervised learning,
and reinforcement learning.
So when the learning doesn't happen at
all, it's rule-based AI or symbolic.
AI, but when learning happens,
it's the machine learning, deep learning,
supervised learning,
unsupervised learning.
all other further learning models.
So that's exactly the difference.
Any questions till now?
OK, so I'll go ahead.
So next we go into reasoning.
So reasoning is a very important,
we will revisit reasoning again, okay?
Because if you look at the evolution of
AI,
initially it started with not much
reasoning. It was more on learning.
And then now we are seeing a reasoning
models.
reaching a lot of importance and momentum,
etc.
So reasoning is the ability to connect
multiple facts, apply the logic,
and then derive new conclusions. Right?
So
We all humans apply reasoning, right?
And if you would have learned in your
maybe some humanities class or some
reasoning classes,
or you would have experienced,
how do you derive at a guaranteed
conclusion from known facts or premises?
Have you heard of this statement like?
If all humans are mortal and Socrates is
human,
then the system can conclude that
Socrates is mortal, right?
So that is a detective reasoning.
right?
And then we have inductive reasoning
where you can identify broad patterns
from specific observations to make a
probabilistic prediction that forms the
foundation for machine learning.
So detective reasoning is very
straightforward, like the rule-based one.
Right,
whereas inductive reasoning is you make
some specific observations and you make
some probabilistic predictions.
This might be the most suitable one, etc.
That is inductive reasoning, right?
When you have then there is also called
the all this abductive reasoning, where...
most likely explanation,
you have a set of observations,
but it is not complete observations.
That is,
you don't have broad patterns or you
don't have large amount of data,
but you have some incomplete set of
observations and you find the most likely
suitable reason.
for that.
It is similar to the medical diagnosis or
troubleshooting.
Like we have a few instances.
So you say this might have happened or
this might be the deceased and then you
go further and look at more parameters or
something which and then you take
decisions, right?
So that is one kind of reason.
So now, the first one,
where AI uses strict mathematical
knowledge and its strict,
predefined if-then rule frameworks,
that is the oldest model,
or I would say it has been there. Still,
it is there in many places.
So, symbolic and knowledge graph AI,
it gives you explicit guaranteed decision
making deductions,
and there is that's been tried and tested,
and we have many systems today.
Then comes the wherever we use a little
bit of inductive reasoning,
you have the probabilistic and
statistical inferences.
So,
based on the likelihood of occurrence on
the incomplete data,
based on statistical distribution of data
or Bayesian networks, etc.
You get some.
mathematical measures based on which you
say this is what is the prediction.
Then the last one is what is more
important today, the chain of thought.
So hallucination or problems with the
early models of ChatGPT and many of our
AI models which we used.
They do well when you ask a very simple
statement, very simple question.
But when you give a very complex task,
okay, now they have improved a lot.
So I'm not talking about today.
Maybe think of how each ChatGPT
when it was introduced in 2022-23 time
frame.
So, what happened during that time is,
once you do a very complex task,
but it involves a certain mathematical
logic to be do,
or wherever there is multi-step problems,
you will see that the model didn't
actually work well.
That is where this chain of thought
reasoning came and played a major role.
So this enables the large language model
to break down the bigger problem into
smaller intermediary logic steps before
generating a response and also
follows a step-by-step thinking.
So,
this is this is the area we will come
back again,
because today all reasoning models has to
follow this,
and this is what has improved the model
itself. So, reasoning, if you take...
It is a system's ability to evaluate
information, apply the logic,
and draw conclusions or solve multi-step
problems that go beyond a simple pattern
match.
Okay,
so here we have to clearly differentiate.
That is a symbolic AI is mostly rule
based. It has explicit knowledge.
It's highly transparent.
It is it comes with guaranteed detections.
It is
explainable, highly explainable.
But that is the weakness with the
symbolic AI is it has,
it cannot work for unprogrammed scenarios.
It has to be programmed.
So if there is an edge case or there is a
deviation,
which is not programmed,
it will not work and it will fail, right?
And it has to have rigid information.
It will struggle with ambiguity, right?
Whereas in the neural AI, the other one,
the probabilistic statistical inference
or the chain of thought, whatever.
You learn from the statistical
associations from massive data sets,
right? So it's flexible,
it can handle ambiguity, noise, etc.
It has a black box nature.
It is based on the data, right?
So it is prone to hallucination.
It strict logic.
You cannot have a deterministic output
coming out of it. Okay,
my voice is lagging. Okay.
Am I audible now?
Yeah.
I hope I'm better. Yeah, okay.
So I'll share the screen again.
Yes, ma'am.
Maybe I think I should have my...
Video switched off just in case if that's
due to that.
And have my video switched off.
Like,
what is a software program is like a
recipe?
Is like, yeah, right. So, OK,
so to the question,
what is the difference between us?
Okay, both are almost same.
It's like rule-based AI is implemented as
a specific type of software program.
So software program is...
More like a rules,
so they act like a rule-based AI,
they act like expert systems,
they capture the human knowledge to
answer or infer answers, and then they...
use it.
So deduction rules are what is being used
in rule-based AI to solve a specific
query. So it's similar.
We are implementing that through the
software program. That's how it is.
And that is when the limitation was there.
So it didn't scale beyond that at all.
It's practically impossible to write so
many rules.
We can never simulate a real-time rules.
So think of,
so that is where the limitation was there
for the rule-based systems in total,
actually.
So I was talking about reasoning, right?
So reasoning, again, we will revisit.
So the symbolic AI is more on.
highly explainable, deterministic one,
but it doesn't work with ambiguity or
unprogrammed scenarios,
whereas the other one, it works well.
But it struggles with hallucination.
It's prone to hallucination,
which is improving. Thus,
strict logic cannot be there.
You cannot always expect the same answer
for every
One, that that's not possible.
So again, this last, the neural reasoning,
the modern LLM reasoning techniques have
been.
gaining a lot of momentum and we have
seen that it has gone into other areas.
We will talk about that in a little more
in detail.
So the chain of thought is the starting
point. Modern generator models,
they can simulate complex reasoning.
using specialized techniques,
prompt techniques and architectural
training.
So first one was the chain of thought
where you prompt the model to break down.
steps before giving the final answer.
And then a tree of thought was in a
further.
technique,
which evaluates multiple potential paths,
forecast the outcomes and backtrack when
a path fails to reach a solution, etc.
And then we have the latest one,
the system 2 thinking,
which we will see in a little more detail.
Like you look at more advanced search
algorithms like the Monte Carlo
search algorithms,
allowing the model to spend more time,
more compute time on thinking and
verifying before getting into the answer,
saying out the answer. So reasoning has,
reasoning to a greater extent,
was still this point, 2024.
Recently,
last two years is where this part is
getting,
we are seeing more reasoning models come
up,
especially when we started using AI for
complex tasks,
which involves a step-by-step execution,
which humans do.
And the third of problem solving.
So this is again, you have a goal.
You want to get into a particular state.
That is what you want to achieve, right?
To do that,
you need a series of steps which needs to
be done,
a series of actions to reach that goal.
So.
That is how an AI will approach it, right?
So how AI approaches it,
first it evaluates what are the existing
options.
So it uses possible feature moves.
So it uses many search algorithms or
optimization algorithms to decide on the
decision spaces.
So,
there are many search algorithms which
are available.
And then there is a planning.
Once you know these are the options
available,
the decision spaces are available,
then comes the planning.
Which divides the task into smaller
subtasks, and also...
Hey, Agent Planning.
This is where most of our discussions are
going to be in the upcoming classes.
When you say ancient, right,
it goes beyond the model.
Because until we talk about models,
it is about the model,
the data is supplied to the model,
how it infers,
how it identifies the relationship, etc.
But when you talk about agents,
it deals with something more.
It is not just a conversation which you
are having with the model.
Right, so when you talk about...
agents, they have to read files.
They don't, it's not one file,
they might have to read multiple files.
Tools in on your behalf,
they might have to call APIs,
so they have to do much more outside the
AI model itself, right? So,
this is where the entire software
engineering itself is evolving. So,
the next topic after today would be,
I will talk about...
how initially we were doing that through
prompt engineering, the planning,
everything was happening through prompt
engineering.
We were trying to say a chain of thought
and we were trying to build some prompt
strategies.
But later we had to do a little bit of...
engineering,
we have to supply a memory to the agents
and then we have harness engineering and
then today we have loop engineering.
So that is what is the flow.
So when it comes to,
when you're talking about only models,
it lies within that.
When you talk about more autonomy,
more autonomous systems coming in.
It is not just the model.
Right.
It is much more than the model.
You have to supply memory to it.
You have to break down,
at least breaking down.
how it reads external tools data,
how it acts with the environment, etc.
All that is what we have to discuss a lot
in detail. And of course,
how do we enforce constraints?
So we have to have a strict criteria.
Late.
So problem solving has three ways.
First is the searching decision spaces.
Second is the planning.
And then how it works based on
constraints.
We might say within this budget you have
to execute.
The number of tokens you can use is only
this.
Or there might be functional constraints.
right,
this has to happen within this limit, etc.
So when it comes to coding,
I might give many other constraints.
I might give something from my static
code analyzer and say this is how it
should look like, all those things.
So it has to work within the constraints,
so that is.
what is our problem solving.
So this is the area where we are going to
see how this can be done in a more
effective way.
So we eliminate all the risks which we
had looked at in the previous places and
use the AI in a more effective way.
The last one is the perception.
It is basically how AI looks at the data,
right?
It how it translates that data into a
meaningful representation,
because without the data,
that forms the base for the learning as
well as for the reasoning, etc. So the
perception is very important.
So it has to look at the data.
So initially,
if it's only text-based data or the basic
machine learning models,
they look at the statistical
relationships in the data.
But when you look at...
neural networks and other.
Pixel.
identify objects,
they look at the depth in real time, etc.
to identify.
So computer missions uses convolutional
neural networks and there are many
transformers,
mission transformers listed here,
but there are many alternate transformers
we are having which they will be using.
And, of course,
speech and audio processing is also a
specialized models which look helps us to
look at the data, right? So...
The statistical relationship, etc.,
can all models will not be able to just
work with text, etc.,
so you have to go into a multi-model.
model models where it combines not just
text but audio, video, images, etc.
And then bring them all into a
statistical space to see and hear context
as a single integrated stream.
Right, so how?
is for perception, learning, reasoning,
and problem solving.
Perception is basically the objective is
to read from raw inputs, right?
So example,
I would say a self-driving car identifies
a red light or identifies a pedestrian
walking.
So,
it perceives the data as a human or an
animal, right? So, that is perception.
Learning is you recognize patterns from
your previous experience,
so you know how fast objects.
millions of driving hours already
documented,
so you know how this can be predicted.
You look at patterns there, right?
And reasoning is you apply rules and
predict the outcomes. So,
so you know a pedestrian is walking,
then you...
Reason OK,
so they are walking at the speed that
might mean they they might come into the
car path in two seconds or less than a
second.
Ex.
is what happens through reasoning, right?
And problem solving is how do you break
this problem when a bigger problem is
given, right?
So a bigger problem like autonomous
driving or you cross the lane is given,
right? How do you break that into, say,
a bigger problem like cross the...
lane safely.
How do you break that into smaller
portions and come up with a smooth
trajectory to follow this and cross?
learning and reasoning,
that's what is more about problem solving.
Right,
so that's how all of them interconnect
with each other.
Okay, let me see in the chat.
A.
Okay.
Asha Parveen has.
I think this clearly explains what a
medical export system is, right?
It is based on inference engine rules.
Now, what is the problem with this, right?
Knowledge is stored as rules,
but can you practically store so many
rules?
Right,
so that is where the problem we have only
ANAND and OR, right?
So it is practically very difficult to
write so many rules and engines,
so that is why they came.
They came stagnant at a certain point;
they were not able to go beyond a certain
level the export systems had,
but still they are good for certain
things, right? With their.
visibility.
So if you can hard code every single step.
Or if you can write all your knowledge as
rules, then it works well.
But not being able to do that,
that is where you have to,
or you don't have options to scale them
further. That is what it is about.
So now we have some understanding for
what an AI will do, right?
learn from that, reason it out,
and use it for problem solving.
That's how it is.
Now let's look at an evolution.
So symbolic logic systems is what we have
been discussing,
so I'm not going into that in detail.
So they are the earliest phase of
AI,
where you have rules and logic principles
to represent the knowledge and come up
with.
conclusion.
So it has been as mentioned in the
example by Parveen as well as based on a
discussion,
they are particularly effective in
structured domains where formal logic
ensures precision.
A logic programming language which is
completely based on 1st order logic.
It allows user to define facts and reason
through queries.
And it has been used a lot in symbolic
reasoning systems in export systems and
Natural language processing.
They use a predicate logic.
for formal reasoning.
And this has been the dominant approach
from the AI based approach.
I didn't put the timelines because I was
not very sure. Roughly,
it should be 60s to 80s, I think.
around that timeframe, I think.
or they were the dominant ways in which
AI was implemented. Then there was some,
I think IBM had one, I forgot their name.
For automated reasoning.
I'll get back to you on that.
So basically,
symbolic logic systems were pivotal
milestones in the early AI development.
They were completely based on formal
logic,
and they worked very well in well-defined
problems and structured environment. But
The downside is limitations that rigid
that they were rigid and they were
rule-based systems,
but despite these constraints,
symbolic logic systems remain the
foundation to the.
And recently.
In the reasoning models,
which I'm going to the last one,
which is there, right,
which we are going to talk, there is LLMs.
have greatly enhanced the human-like
system,
cognitive process of the systems and the
reasoning models.
So there is some concept which I will not
get into detail,
but I'm giving you a simple idea that
there is something called as macro action
frameworks.
Right.
What does that do is it combines the
symbolic templates and rules which have
been there in the traditional AI with the
modern foundational elements.
Which is helping to.
Singing, came from the lips.
So,
what happens when you actually integrate
macro actions into foundational LLMs,
right?
It is the ability to handle complex
reasoning tasks, right?
Because when you break down a bigger
complex problem into smaller steps and
you don't want any step to be.
right there you need a rigid system,
a structured system, right?
So a hierarchical planning.
Then we need a logic structured approach.
So when you want to make high level
decisions before getting into the problem,
say for example,
you don't want to skip testing at any
cost. There is one,
maybe you add a feature or something,
you don't want to skip that testing at
all, right?
What LLMs have been doing?
I have read somewhere I couldn't read the
exact reference,
but recently the last week I read I was
reading a paper,
so it was saying that LLMs before
reasoning when they are when they are
running out of.
token or when they have very less tokens
which are going to expire,
they start to skip steps,
validation steps which they have to do in
order to complete fast and give the
output. That is what they have been doing.
So when we do not want such things to
happen.
And we want for at any cost follow a
structured approach.
That is where you can bring back the
symbolic approach and integrate it.
to handle complex reasoning tasks, etc.
So recently such a macro action thing is
also available. I think I have the,
I have attached this.
Ohh.
I'll just check, I think I attached the.
Referencing.
for your reading, but if not,
also I will check and I will add it. Okay,
so macro action in decision making is you
divide the sequence,
you bring in the formal methods which we
have used into the planning,
so you can enforce.
a structured logic, right?
So that was the initial,
so symbolic logic systems that are our
initial ones.
Now this is the traditional machine
learning which we have discussed about.
So it starts with supervised.
Learning,
we have classification prediction.
regression and then we have logistic
regression for classification,
all those models which mainly relied on
the data,
the mathematics behind the data execution.
That was the traditional mission learning
one.
Now,
deep learning is a subset of machine
learning,
which is derived mostly from the...
Neural networks, a multi-layer neural.
It is basically inspired by the structure
of a human brain,
so what deep learning model is?
Uh...
Basically a neural network.
Today,
most of the artificial intelligence
improvements we have seen, right,
from computer vision, generative AI,
to self-driving cars, all that,
deep learning is the foundation, right?
Unlike the well-defined mathematical
logic of traditional machine learning,
The neural networks.
Of deep learning models, they have a.
Many interconnected layers of neurons
that each have a mathematical operation.
And in a machine learning algorithm,
the mathematical logic was explicitly
defined and it remained.
Here you have interconnected layers of
neuron,
each performing A mathematical operation.
Therefore,
you apply machine learning to adjust the
strength of the connection.
between each of the neurons in the
adjacent layers.
So that is what is called as model
weights and biases.
And this is used to optimize the output
to get more accurate outputs.
By neural networks,
and deep learning have been closely
associated with one another.
It is not similar, OK?
It doesn't mean deep learning means it's
only neural networks.
Deep learning refers to training of
models with at least 4 layers and above.
That is what deep learning is referred to.
OK.
So, imagine you have a.
training data as data points on a
two-dimensional graph.
Right, a simple model,
the goal of the model,
say we have some data points.
Scattered in a two-dimensional graph. OK,
so the goal of a model training is to be
finding a line which cuts through each of
the data points, right? So,
what mission training?
Then we will do is to we will try to find
a line curve,
a single line or a curve which a single
which is represented by a single
mathematical function.
Right, whereas what deep learning,
so we try to see which line fits this
data well,
or which curve fits this data well, etc.
Whereas deep learning, on the other hand,
can...
Put together a smaller individual lines.
Form our desired shapes. OK,
so it will be small individual adjustable
lines to form the desired shape,
and then it...
Also has back propagation through which
it can go back and adjust the weight.
After seeing the result,
it can adjust the weight and the biases
to the more accurate results.
So deep learning models,
if you look at them.
They have been mainly through supervised
learning, that is,
they you have a lot of labeled data to
perform.
form regression and classification and
deep learning neural networks were
learning from that using the multi-layer
perceptron, et cetera,
and they were able to give you the output.
But the practical difficult.
As I told you earlier,
they require a massive amount of training
data to reach an optimal performance,
and it is not so easy to acquire large
data sets of labeled data, right?
It involves cost as well as it involves.
Label,
it's not easy to actually label data,
so that is when the deep learning model.
went into a transition.
And it led to a development of techniques
to replicate supervised learning tasks
using unlabeled data.
So it is not unsupervised learning.
It is supervised learning,
but with unlabeled data.
So that is called as.
self-supervision,
which is what was the foundation for
large language models.
and many other language models which we
are.
Okay,
I come to this a little more in detail.
So.
Deep learning models were supervised
learning on labeled data,
but the problem is it required a large
amount of data,
which was not practically possible.
The cost and labor was very high.
So that was when self-supervision came in.
Those neural networks were there earlier
in the history.
The breakthrough didn't happen until late
2000s or 2010, I think.
I have given around 2017,
but it's a little early,
but for deep learning foundation LLMs is
what 2017 is,
but it didn't happen much because of the
compute power we didn't have,
so the deep learning networks were still..
.
in more preliminary stage or research
stage because we didn't have good
computing power.
Then the advancement in high performance
graphic GPUs enabled parallel processing
of massive amounts of computational step.
And that is when both training and
inferences could happen.
So,
hardware enhancements greatly increase
the speed and practicality of the deep
learning models at a larger. OK,
now going back.
the language model and what is
self-supervision, right?
So large language models are a category
of deep learning models only,
trained on immense amount of data,
making them capable of...
understanding and generating natural
language and other types of content as
well. Now, LLMs are also built on,
based on neural networks and their
architecture is called transformers,
which I will talk about shortly.
So what, before going into language,
large language models, LLMs,
let's talk about what is language model
as such, right?
So a language model is something which
encodes statistical information about one
or more languages.
Basically, in simple words,
it tells us how likely a word is likely
to appear in a given context. That is,
what is a large language?
Right, so, for example,
if I say my favorite color is dash, right,
a language model that encodes or
understands English should predict a
color, right? So,
it should say my favorite color is blue,
red, yellow,
instead of saying my favorite color is a
car or a bike or a.
Dogs, right?
So that is what a language model should
tell.
The statistical nature of languages are
not something very new. Okay,
they have been discovered centuries ago.
So there are many examples.
This AI engineering book,
which is one of your reference books,
it talks about Sherlock Holmes.
I have not seen that.
movie or that I've not read that
particular one,
but it says that in one of the Sherlock
Holmes story,
Sherlock Holmes leveraged the statistical
information of English to decode the most
in English and E is the most common
letter in English.
etc.
But there are many statistical natures of
the language.
There are many studies even before AI to
understand how words and letters are
related to each other.
There are many statistical studies.
There are papers on prediction,
entropy of languages,
how much information.
It includes, et cetera, right?
So many concepts were introduced earlier,
entropies.
So if you ask me what is entropy in very..
.
Okay, my voice is again breaking.
Ma'am, it is mostly clear,
but sometimes there is a break between,
you know, few words are getting.
Okay. Okay, fine.
Okay,
let's all take a quick 5 minute break.
In the meantime,
I will see if I can switch network and
come back. Okay,
so we take a 5 minute break.
I will be back.
Within the time I will fix the network
issue and come back.
Okay, so let me continue.
I hope my audio is clear now.
I have switched a network.
Let's see how it goes. Okay,
so I was talking about the language model
before getting into the language model.
Right, a large language model,
so the statistical nature.
Of the language was discovered many years
ago, and there are many studies on that,
so entropy is 1 mean.
Parameter used in a language modeling
today, so...
When we say language model,
it includes statistical information about
one or more languages, right?
So in early days when we talked about
language model,
it involved only one language.
But today when we say language model,
it includes more than,
or it involves multiple languages.
So the basic unit of a language model is
a token.
So we'll talk about more on tokenization,
etc. But a token can be a character,
a word, or a part of a word,
depending on the model.
So different models do different ways of
dividing the text into.
tokens. Okay,
I will have a small example which I will
show you later also.
So the process of breaking the original
text into token,
that is what is called as tokenization.
And all the tokens a model can work with,
right? If you take a text model,
it can work with all text in English.
That is the model's vocabulary.
So now.
If you look at.
These models.
We can describe them as two basic types.
Right,
a language model can be described as two
main types.
Yes,
the language model and the language is
like our natural language, English,
German. That's how it is, French. Yes,
that's right.
So a language model consists of how one
or more languages,
it consists of information,
statistical information about that
particular language.
So, initially,
we were saying a language model was
particularly.
Okay.
I think so.
The network is launched.
Okay, let me see how much I can go. Okay,
so I'll continue now.
So there are two types of language models.
Eight.
What is a master language model,
a master language model?
I have not added the names there,
but the AI engineering book has those
names. Maybe I'll add it later.
And then there is auto-regressive
language model.
So when I say masked language model,
it is basically trained to predict
missing tokens in a sequence.
It will have a context before and after
the word. It's like fill in the blanks.
It will have a statement.
So say, for example,
my favorite dash is blue, right?
So it has a context before that is my
favorite,
and it has a context after is blue.
So it uses the context before and after
to fill up the blank.
That is called as a masked language model.
And there are the BERT,
there are many famous examples,
so bidirectional encoder representations
from transformers or BERT,
all these come under the masked language
models.
Okay, my voice is too much.
They do.
Yeah, true, it's Friday effect, I think.
Even they didn't want to have the class.
Okay, give me two minutes.
I will see a last try using my other
network if that works.
Otherwise, we will stop for today early,
and we will go back, OK?
I will continue tomorrow. I will see.
Give me a last.
Option, let me try.
Okay, am I audible now?
Okay, okay, so let's see how this goes.
So I was talking about a masked language
model and a autoregressive model.
So these are two types of language models.
So when I say masked language model,
it has a context before and after.
And it is like fill in the blanks.
It fills in the missing tokens, right?
And there are many encoder
representations from transformers and
many models.
And where we use masked languages more is
for non-generative tasks.
Like you want to classify your text or
you want to do a sentimental.
analysis, right?
So those kind of places is where we will
use a lot of masked language model.
They are useful for tasks which are have
an understanding of the overall context.
Like for example,
code debugging we can use. It has.
Both the preceding and the,
as well as the code to identify the error,
but if you cannot use it to.
Code, but for debugging we can use,
so that is a masked model,
that is the auto-regressive model.
is trained to predict the next token in a
sequence using only the preceding tokens.
It does not have anything after the
tokens.
It is only used on the preceding tokens.
It is predicting the next possible token.
So autoregressive model can continuously
generate one token after the other.
other. Right,
so today all our text generations is
based on autoregressive model.
Now what is,
so whatever we are speaking will be
mostly on the auto regressive model. Okay,
now the main thing which we have to,
what makes this different or what made
this ChatGPT movement or the entire
language movement? Language is.
Language modeling is just one of the many
ML algorithms and they have been existing
for a very long time.
They were used for object detection,
they were using for recommender systems,
weather forecasting,
they were used for stock price
predictions, et cetera.
This was happening for quite a long year,
but what?
Induced this.
ChatGPT movement or what made this
language models the center or how did it
scale to what we are having today was the
concept of self-supervision.
Okay,
I told you the problem with unsupervised.
Supervised learning is good,
but you cannot label so much of data,
right?
The the language models.
Had an option.
To be.
Have a self-supervision.
Supervision means that it has a.
process of training ML algorithms using
labeled data.
And we know it's not possible,
it is expensive, it is slow to obtain,
et cetera.
So what self-supervision means is it
overcomes the data labeling bottleneck.
to create large,
because we have to create large data sets
for models to learn from,
which is effectively not possible,
and to do it at this scale.
So with supervision.
We give the clear label data, and then it.
learns it right. The success of AI models.
or the accuracy of AI models,
supervised AI models was very high.
Then came the unsupervised one, right?
The initial deep learning models also
were supervised to a certain extent,
but it is time consuming, so we cannot.
Practically label because data labeling
is very expensive.
And the number of labels we would require,
a number of data sets,
and we have to cross-check the quality.
All that is very difficult.
Right?
So self-supervision is 1 which overcomes
this bottleneck.
Instead of requiring explicit labels,
the model can infer labels from the input
data itself. That was the concept. Okay,
this name itself was given a
self-supervision.
by an author, by a research scientist,
to ensure that it is not confused with
unsupervision or supervised learning.
Okay,
so language modeling is self-supervised
because in each input sequence,
it provides the labels,
the tokens to be predicted,
and it also uses the context the model
can use to predict these labels.
So it is given,
so it learns from the input.
The language model can learn from the
text sequences without explicitly
requiring labeling. So if you say text,
right,
there are so many text sequences
everywhere. Today,
internet has so many blogs, books,
articles, comments.
social media has so much of information.
So it is easily possible to construct a
massive amount of training data,
allowing the language models to scale up
to become what they have today using
self-supervision.
And this was one of the major turning
point because we were not practically
able to scale with supervised learning
and with unsupervised learning we were
not expect getting the.
scale accuracy we had expected and
self-supervision is what actually made
the real change for us.
So when you say large language models,
it's not.
Um...
a very, it's a very subjective term,
right? How do you say how much is large?
It's not possible.
What is large today might be tiny
tomorrow, right?
That's what happened with our compute
resources and all, right?
So we started with 256 MB RAM, 512 MB RAM,
then 1 GB.
GB, 8 GB, we have increased, right?
So 8 GB RAM was considered a very big
compute resources few years back,
but now it is not even sufficient for
many of our products we have to use today,
right?
So the term large is very subjective.
So a model size is typically measured by
its number of parameters.
What is a parameter?
If you ask me in very simple terms,
that is updated during the training
process and it can be tweaked to get
better accuracy, better results.
Right,
so a parameter is a variable within the
model that is updated during the training
process based on the information.
Though it is not always true.
The more parameters a model has,
greater is its capacity to learn desired
behaviors.
OK, so then open API.
Sorry, Open AI released the first GPT.
By the way, what is the full form of GPT?
It is a generative,
pre-trained transformer.
Transformer is the architecture behind a
large language model.
Right,
so it's a generator model which can
generate information.
It is already pre-trained and it's a
based on transformer architecture.
So when Open AI released GPT model in
2018, it had some 100 million parameters,
so I think 117.
around 1 parameters and during that time
that was considered large.
Then when GPT2 it the parameter scaled to
billions.
Right, so then again,
it is now it is more, I think,
and perhaps in one some other day in the
future,
the size also might be considered small,
etcetera.
So LLM basically works as a statistical
prediction mission,
a giant statistical prediction mission
that repeatedly predicts the next word in
a sequence.
So they learn the patterns in the text
and they generate language that follows
these patterns.
So, LLM was a major leap in humans,
or how they how humans interacted with
technology.
or how humans interacted with AI.
and how systems can handle unstructured
language, natural language.
And that led to what momentum we are
having today and many other AI changes we
are going to see in the future.
If you look at the traditional search
engines, they used algorithms.
To match keywords,
whereas large language models will look
at a deeper context and reasoning.
Now, LLM, the name itself says no,
it's pre-trained. So LLM is trained.
And once it is trained,
it can adapt to many applications.
That can interpret.
summarizing an article, debugging a code,
drafting a new essay for you. Right?
Now that is where LLM stops.
It's just you ask something and it gives.
But with agentic AI capabilities,
LLMs can perform the task with a degree
of autonomy.
Right,
which was earlier performed by humans.
Now they get the autonomy and the with a
agent capabilities, they can do much more.
Right. Now, whatever LLM thing,
it is not just one day,
it's not a magic wand which came out of
nowhere, etc.
It is a culmination of many technologies,
many research work happened in natural
language, machine learning research, etc.
So they all have brought generative AI to
the forefront for the public interest,
right?
So now we have all the LLMs accessible
through, we have ChatGPT, we have Copilot,
Gemini, all those things available.
So the large is about the number of
parameters it is having.
So it works with the large number of text.
Now,
one more important thing is something you
have to understand is large language
models. When I say language model,
it works only with text. OK,
but we need models which work.
More than text.
Right, so.
I'll tell you.
Very important thing.
So initially when ChatGPT was introduced,
When we used to give assignments and all
we used to see a lot of ChatGPT usage.
in the answers, etc.
So in order to defend that and prevent
students from using it,
because we were not,
it was very short of a time to translate,
to acknowledge AI usage or we,
all of us were in the transition phase,
etc.
So what we used to do as faculty members
is give certain questions or image-based
questions in assignments, et cetera,
so that they cannot use ChatGPT because
that time it was only text-based, right?
But of course,
ChatGPT also evolved and we all also
started accommodating AI.
We came up with the AI policy, all that.
So the evolution happened in both places,
but that's how it is.
It started with the large language model
started as a, I mean,
large language models is still a
text-based model only. But today,
what powers?
The ChatGPT or Gemini or all this is not
just a large language model,
but a foundation model.
They are now called as foundation model.
which has self supervision,
which I told you,
because deep learning models initially
were supervised learning on large data,
but since it's very difficult to do this
labeling and all,
we moved to the self-supervised learning.
Now a few more things about large
language models is
Um...
The self-attention.
I think I'll talk about that in the...
Transformers, yeah,
next slide I have on transformers. OK, OK,
before talking about transformers.
the self-attention, etc.
So transformers are nothing but the
architecture based on how the large
language models work. Okay, before that,
I will talk about the transition from
large language models to foundation
models.
So while language models are capable of
all the important,
incredible tasks we are talking about,
they were
But we have a lot of other information.
We perceive the world,
humans perceive the world not only
through text, right? We vision, hearing,
touch, and much more.
So for AI to operate in real world,
it has to go beyond text.
So large language models started getting
extended to incorporate more data
modalities. So GPT-4,
Cloud 3 started understanding images and
text.
Some models today even understand videos.
protein structures,
3D structures they understand and so on.
Right?
So incorporating data modalities into
language models makes them even more
powerful.
And this incorporating multiple
modalities like image video into LLM has
been one of the key frontiers lately in
the AI research and development.
While many people still
But many of us still call chat the GPT as
an LLM, Gemini as an LLM. Today,
they are the better word that fits them
as the foundation model,
because the word foundation signifies
that.
the importance of these models in AI,
right?
The world foundation gives a more better
impact. And in fact,
they can be built upon different needs.
So foundation models made a breakthrough
from the traditional structure of AI by
extending into different data modalities.
So natural language processing
predominantly dealt with text.
Computer vision deals with only with
vision.
Text-only models can be used for tasks
such as translation, spam detection,
all these.
Image models were used for object
detection, image classifications,
et cetera.
And audio only models were used for
speech recognition, speech synthesis, etc.
So,
when a model can work with more than one
data modality, it becomes multi-modal,
multi-modal model,
and a generator multi-modal model is
again a large language model,
but it is multi-modal in nature, right?
It's a multi-modal in nature.
So if a language model generates the next
token.
tokens.
The multi-modal model generates the next
token on text and image based on the
images as well. Right?
So foundation models are what we are
having today,
which forms the base for all our many of
the advancements.
we have and this foundational LLMs.
What we have today?
Are based on the Transformers.
With the introduction of this pre-trained
transformers is where this entire LLN
thing came up.
Right, so what exactly?
Transformers are is basically an
architecture.
You have to train the.
Model with large amount of massive data.
and it's broken down into tokens.
The data is,
the text is broken down into tokens.
And they start initially,
initially started with self-supervised
learning,
which self-supervised learning means it's
a machine learning technique.
But it uses unlabeled data for supervised
learning.
It doesn't require labeled data set,
but it is closely related to supervised
learning.
and tasks are designed such that the
ground truth can be inferred from the
unlabeled data.
So the model then passes the tokens,
whatever has been the tokens which has
been divided from the input text, right?
It passes it through a transformer
networks.
So transformer model,
which was introduced in the paper,
attention is all you need.
Many of you would have heard about that
paper. If you have not,
Heard about it, I will.
Very useful.
You can try the entire visualization.
I have what I have put on this slide.
I think thank you for Hari Narayanan to
share that.
So that shows the entire transformer
architecture, how it evolves.
So first the data is broken down into
tokens and the token is fed into
the transformer architecture.
So the useful thing is a self-attention
mechanism,
which basically in simple words,
this particular transformer model can pay
attention to different tokens at
different moments.
So that was the centerpiece of
transformer and its prime innovation.
So it allows the AI model to calculate
the relationship as well as dependencies
between tokens,
especially ones that are distance.
So it uses a semantics distance.
Measurement.
the text and the tokens with one another,
how distant are they from one another.
And transformer architecture,
another good thing is it also allows for
parallelization,
which makes the process much more
efficient than the previous ones.
So this made it
To be handled to large data set,
so once the text is split into tokens,
each token is mapped with a vector of
numbers,
so that process is called as embedding.
So if you let me stop sharing this and
try to share, that's...
You can parallel be open that also.
OK, so you can you can see the steps.
You can read about it more later,
but the first step is tokenization step.
So whatever text you give here, right?
And once you click on generate,
it divides them into tokens.
So that is the step one.
OK, so once the step one is over,
the next step is embedding step two.
The embedding happens. OK,
so embedding basically it gives you a.
each of the tokens to vector of it is map
each token is mapped to a vector of
numbers.
And then it neural networks consists of
layers of artificial neurons.
Each neuron will perform a mathematical
operation.
So transformers have many of these layers.
And at each layer,
the embeddings is slightly adjusted,
becoming more richer contextual
representation from layer to layer.
So in this process,
what happens is the model learns the
semantic association between the words.
So if there are words like bark and dog,
It knows that it appears closer together
in the vector space in an essay about
dogs.
In.
If the essays are about a tree,
then bark and tree would appear together.
So that's how it.
Understands that.
Uh, what and predict the next token,
so you can uh...
Look at it in a more detailed way.
And now this is a very basic. Again,
audio is breaking. No, no.
So you can look at this in a very
detailed way later sometime.
And now one point I would like to stress
here is the transformer itself has
undergone a lot of changes today.
We have so many transformer architectures.
It has evolved.
There are so many variations also.
Okay, so that is why.
We have different,
there is a lot of research and test
happening on it.
But basically,
it tries to convert a text into token and
then assigns A vector of numbers called
embedding.
And then it tries to predict based on the
semantic association between the words.
It also adds positional encodings,
which gives each token information about
the place it has in the sequence.
and to compute the attention.
Each embedding has three distinct
vectors: a query, a key, and a value.
So the query basically is what a given
token is looking for. See key.
The key represents the information that
each token contains and the value returns
the information from each key vector.
And I think
It is scaled by the respective weights.
So then the scores are calculated.
So it computes the attention,
then the score, again,
the scores are then computed and then it
looks at once they are normalized, etc.
There is a little bit of process there,
which we can try right now,
treat it as a black box.
So basically,
self-attention creates a weighted
connection between all the tokens.
So, the model.
relationship between the token.
And there can be billions and trillions
of these weights,
which are one type of LLM parameter.
So if you look at the parameters,
there are so many parameters, et cetera,
how it processes it, et cetera.
So then it predicts the next world.
So that's more on a transformer
architecture.
So you can see the visualization there.
So it undergoes,
the weights undergo multiple iterations,
back propagation,
and also gradient descent.
The model learns the weights in the
layers that produce the query key value
vectors.
And once you,
once they feel that it is sufficiently
optimized.
and they are able to take in any tokens
original vector and produce that data,
then they produce the end result.
That's roughly how the large.
What?
Now,
the last one which I would like to
discuss.
is the latest reasoning model.
What is a reasoning model?
It is the evolution of the large language
model.
Which has been trained to perform a
multi-step problem or a complex problem
by generating the intermediary steps,
which are called as the...
Reason the traces of how it is recently.
Right.
It has been trained to employ a chain of
thought reasoning and multi-step decision
making strategies.
The reasoning model have been the latest
cutting edge.
Development in LLM performance,
especially when it comes to coding and
mathematics related tasks.
Wherever we have a lot of logical
reasoning,
the LLM performance has improved because
of this, them doing the reasoning. So,
originally...
They were a separate type of models
called thinking models,
which they tried to introduce. But today,
many of the models, LLM models,
are reasoning models only.
So it was lately in 2024 only the
reasoning model term was introduced.
Basically, I think it was...
Open AI gave one and Google Gemini had
one, I think so.
And then 2025,
deepseek-r1 model was the first major
milestone in terms of reasoning LLMs.
What here it is that it produces a trace.
The training process itself has
fine-tuned prior reasoning models.
And DeepSeek, actually,
they released a paper, technical paper,
which should be useful for other model
developers. But in simple terms,
A model before giving an output,
they take time to think.
Right. So we also do that.
So there is something called a system one
and system 2 thinking.
So this is outside LLM or the outside AI.
So in the book, Thinking Fast and Slow,
the author Daniel represents 2 modes of
cognitive processing.
One is a fast, immediate reaction,
quick decisions we make based on patterns,
judgments, experiences, etc.
Quick decisions we make.
And system 2 thinking is a conscious,
slow decision we take for complex problem
solving analytic tasks where more thought
and consideration is necessary.
Right.
So this reasoning model was developed
more as a system 2 thinking, right?
System one and system 2 thinking was
given by Daniel.
It doesn't have any relation with AI,
but we refer to it when in context of
reasoning,
AI research papers always refer it as
system one thinking and system 2 thinking.
Thinking system one thinking is when the
LLM produces the output without the
reasoning being displayed, etcetera,
whereas in system two it talks about.
the reasoning steps. So basically,
reasoning LLMs are trained to spend more
time thinking before they respond.
So this addition of reasoning process has
empirically showed major advancements in
the performance for complex reasoning
task.
And this has been expanded to real world
use cases, especially coding.
logical reasoning tasks and it became a
very important thing in the development
of AI generative AI and AI agents.
OK, so.
Basically,
a more accurate statement would be
reasoning LLMs are trained to show their
thought process by generating a sequence
of words that resembles a human thought
process.
And this act of verbalizing thought
seemed to unlock many reasoning
capabilities that LLM
initially had with the massive amounts of
training data, but it was not explicitly.
So implicitly it had that information,
but it was not giving the right answer.
But when it was asked to reason how it
came with the process,
it was able to unlock that capability.
So adding a thought process to the model
output mitigates many of the flaws which
was there in the standard LLM inferences.
So I will show you one example which will
give you the clarity.
So, this is an example from the paper.
Yes, to system to attention is something.
You might need to, OK,
so that is the paper name, OK, so...
In this,
how do these reasoning models work is?
System one thinking is fast,
as I told you, and it relies on,
it takes without any much effort.
System 2 thinking is logical,
requires a concentrated effort.
By default, the standard LLMs we had,
they were autoregressive LLMs,
they were more inclined to system one
thinking only.
So system one thinking is still,
I would not say can be eliminated,
it is still effective and computationally
efficient. But for many other
places where it involves complex tasks,
that is where we need a system to
thinking.
So, here in this paper.
The model is instructed first to generate
a rewritten version of the input prompt.
Stripping out all the irrelevant content.
and then it is being asked to generate
the output.
You, Bob.
Did anyone ask something?
OK, I think that was a mistake. OK,
so what the system was asked is,
rewrite the prompt with the way you
understand.
right, and then produce the output.
So the left side,
what you see here is a direct output.
So here, if you see, it's very evident,
right?
Mary has three times as much as candy as
Megan.
Then when Mary adds 10 more pieces of
candy to her collection.
Then there are a few irrelevant
information.
Max has thousand more books than Mary.
and then the relevant information,
how many candies does Mary have in total,
etc. So now because of this,
Max has 100 more books.
Since it is taking a very immediate
decision, you see this kind of an output.
when a non-reasoning model is used.
And when a reasoning system to attention
model is used,
it has been asked to rewrite the input
prompt, right?
So system in this experiment is the
system to thinking attention.
outperformed the standard inference on
many tasks, right? So it was able to...
List out.
That Mary has three times candy may have
then adds 10 more pieces,
and you can clearly see that this
irrelevant statement has been removed,
and with this information it clearly gave
you the right answer.
Right.
So the goal of reasoning approaches,
this is 1 behavior.
It is not the only behavior.
There are much more reasoning model
behaviors,
but I'm just showing this as an example.
So the foundation for modern thinking
models or the reasoning models is that
they think step by step.
And they follow a chain of thought
prompting.
They give reasoning traces on how they
are thinking through.
They are asked to list down their steps,
so which makes them more better in terms
of performance than the standard LLMs
which were giving the.
output and that is what we are having
today. So it goes beyond.
Modern reasoning LLMs go further.
They use.
Today, many complex tasks,
especially coding related tasks,
mathematics related tasks, all that.
Are able to.
perform well because of this reasoning
models and we are seeing the difference
also.
A few years or months back when we used
the ChatGPT or Copilot or even Claude to
produce the output and what we are seeing
today,
they are getting improvised on a daily
basis and we are seeing.
as the new models come.
We are seeing the difference also.
Right now we have discussed about all the
models, the evolution.
I would like to map it with the use case
so that we get the clear idea.
So let's take a real world use case like
an.
automated code bugs fixing.
So you have a critical bug in a
microservices code base. Okay,
so if I have only a traditional ML model
and ask it to fix it,
what it can do or what it is capable of
doing is it will identify which line or
file contains a bug.
based on the previous commit logs or
based on the previous data,
log classification data which it has.
And it will provide you the line which
has the error.
But it cannot go beyond that.
It cannot evaluate the fix or produce the
right output.
Good for you.
That is a standard LLM which considered
the chat based ChatGPT we had in the
early a few years before 2025 or 2024.
It had the capability to identify the bug
and it will write a rewrite a patch for
you, but it might not be 100% accurate.
It might cause some other problems,
it might not work.
When you try to use it in your code,
it might have certain problems or it
might miss a edge case.
or it might skip a test or it might fail
a few tests.
Because it had it basically it had a
system one thinking,
plus it it did have many contexts.
It worked on a single file, basic mostly,
or even if it had the capability to work
with multiple files, it context was small.
Plus, it worked in a single pass, right?
But today, the reasoning model,
if you give the Copilot and Claude,
we have, so Copilot is not a model.
Copilot is the tool.
It has the options for selecting
whichever model we want. And in Claude,
we have Office and other models.
So, those reasoning models,
they have the loss.
Sorry, so they have the option.
It executes the internal thought process.
It bases the call stack across the
service mentally.
It goes through the identifies the root
cause. It also changes the running code.
If you want,
you can have the mandatory test fixed.
You can write guardrails that.
mandatorily this test should be done
using prompt engineering, etc.
And it drafts the fix,
double checks for dependencies,
and then only it gives you the final
answer.
Right now, in this, it is already better.
Still, we are having problems today,
still we are having problems,
still we are having some hallucinations,
still we are having some problems.
As I told you,
the reason one example that tokens are
going to expire, it goes,
it skips certain validation steps and
gives the output.
So that is where on top of these,
though the models are getting better.
B as.
Software engineers have to do a little
bit of work.
So there is prompt engineering,
there is harness engineering,
all those terms we will discuss in our
upcoming classes.
So that is where we have to expand more.
and we have to see how this can be more
made more deterministic, more reliable.
Though from traditional to standard to
reasoning, we have seen the improvement,
but still there is a lot of engineering
you have to do,
which is more about AI engineering or
whatever term they are calling it today.
I would say it is modern software
engineering in simple words.
but it can be a loop engineering or
harness engineering or whatever,
but we are working around this to improve
and make it more reliable.
So I'll stop here today.
This is an additional slide.
on the tokens.
So we'll start talking about tokens
tomorrow. Okay, so you can use this link.
I will paste this link in the chat also.
You can use this link to see how
different models generate different
tokens based on the text.
Everyone doesn't come up with the same
number of tokens.
Okay,
so we will start the discussion tomorrow
with tokens and we will continue further.
OK.
So, for the...
As of now, please refer,
stick to the PPTs and the reference
materials which I'm sharing.
I think that should be sufficient.
To answer.
Sonar Sahil's question.
Are the ones that you have shared,
those some articles and other things,
or are those from handout?
No, no, I have shared.
I'm at the end of the slide,
plus I'm also putting up a document in
Teams, which where I'm sharing the links.
Okay, thank you.
Ma'am, for other subjects,
we have some past year, you know,
Okay.
question papers,
but this is a very new subject.
So can we get some sort of mock questions,
like, you know,
Mm.
to understand how our exam paper will
look like? Just some mock examples, maybe.
Sure,
I will try to generate some mock thing.
This is a course which is getting offered
from only from this semester.
So we don't have any past question papers.
So I will try to give you a idea.
Thank you.
For the assignment, as I told you,
it will be a coding, I mean,
it will be a hands-on assignment.
So we will do all the phases of
stSemAIMLstudentsdocs,
right from design to coding, testing,
all that.
For quiz, it is an NCQ.
Okay, thank you all.
We'll meet again tomorrow evening for the
next session.